do you have any creepy stories from your
own life yeah I do actually have one
from when I was a little kid I'd woken
up in the night and where my bedroom was
a door frame looked out down
down the hallway of the second floor and
this figure which I assumed was my mum
walked out of her bedroom door across
the corridor all dressed in white I
called out mum and the figure just
turned their face to look towards me
then looked back and then just walked
back into the room without answering me
when she looked at you could you tell
that if it was your mom or not no
because it was Pitch Black it was really
really dark and I feel like if it was
her she would have answered me and when
I mentioned it to her the next morning
she had no recollection she didn't know
what I was talking about and I don't
know what's her reaction I think did she
freak out that there's somebody in the
house
I think she just missed it as just her
child's dreaming but it just always gave
me the creeps let us know if you have
any scary stories of your own in the
comments